it may not look like much but this is
Ground Zero for one of the world's
fastest growing
Sports here on the outskirts of East
London a Swedish entrepreneur is
building the city's biggest center for
the hottest new thing in recreational
sport P so this is going to be the
Center Court and then we have another
five courts all the way down to the main
entrance over there we started looking
for opportunities back in
2019 and then after covid uh we we got
our first Club up uh which is Bristol
the rocket pedal Bristol is the largest
pedal Club in the country holding 14
courts it's a very very nice club so we
opened up that club and now we're
focusing a little bit more on London so
now we're trying to surround London this
usually one of the bottlenecks in
scaling paddle is to get clubs and
premises like this but once you have the
proper clubs up the land owners will
find us rather than us finding them and
trying to convince them to change the
use I think if you open up in a very uh
well populated area where where there's
lots of experience from paddle and a
strong demand already you could be
breaking profits earlier whereas when
you start in New cities that when we
open up in Bristol for example people
didn't really understand or know about
paddle so it took a couple of extra
months to get them coming and trying it
out and coming back back usually you
should be able to be in the money from
an operational perspective within 3 to 6
months paddle was invented in the 1960s
by a Mexican businessman who didn't have
enough space to build a tennis court at
his house in Acapulco instead he
designed a smaller enclosed Court which
gave rise to a new Pursuit mixing
elements of tennis and squash paddle
went on to become a huge hit in Spain
Argentina and a handful of other places
around the world typically played in
doubles paddle has been gaining
popularity for being sociable but easy
to pick up it uses tennis scoring but
has a glass wall for returning shots as
in squash now investors are looking for
the next big opportunity with the UK the
US France and Germany in Focus globally
the game is estimated to be worth
around2 billion a year but is forecast
to treble in size over the next 3 years
padd's an interesting sport right now I
think it is growing quite quickly the
pace of change in terms of paddle and
the business model of paddle is changing
quite quickly obviously you have CO as
an inflection point where people were
working from home and wanted to
socialize have fun compete a little bit
so that's where a sport like paddle can
come into play quite easily I think
we're at an early stage when it comes to
the growth of paddle in the UK the us
some of these Emerging Markets I think
you're starting to see this postco boom
of wanting to socialize wanting to
exercise in a way that isn't necessarily
just going to the gym anymore one of the
big challenges for paddle Advocates is
spreading the word about a sport many
have never heard of but Sandy and Tom
farers saw the potential early on and
set up the paddle School an online video
platform to teach people how to play and
how to improve their game understanding
the back glass and getting yourself in a
good position to hit is one of the more
difficult areas of paddle just a normal
flat ball so paddle is a mixture of of
tennis and squash it's similar scoring
to tennis but they use different rackets
and lower pressured balls so the racket
is smaller it's often described as a
beach bat and therefore your contact is
a lot closer to your hand also the court
is a lot shorter than a tennis court for
example and the more you play the more
you realize that it's quite a different
sport from tennis and squash it kind of
sits on its own well the great thing
about paddle is that the serve is
technically easier than tennis so to
start with paddle it's an underarm serve
you play the ball crosscourt and and
that is how simple it is to start the
point in paddle and having taught lots
and lots of adult tennis players and and
adult paddle players it's amazing that
inad you can literally start the first
day and play some points whereas in
tennis you would need lessons in order
to be able to serve so initially I
started the the video content online
really to help my own group of students
I was in Dubai I had a small group of
students and they were asking me the
same questions over and over again and
and there was no content in English in
this video today we're going to talk
about how to return the board
that comes off that side glass with
slice tip number three is recognize your
opponent's serving technique I was
really trying to help my students play
the game but I was starting to see
through the analytics that you know a
lot of the Nordic countries in Sweden
were were really taking it up and
watching a lot of those videos and
initially it was teaching technique and
the rules and the basics but as the the
channel improved and grew there were
more and more questions and therefore
more and more titles and topics for me
to select really it's not just
recreational paddle that is gaining
attention investors have been putting
money into professional tours leagues
and Cup competitions including the likes
of Qatar Sports investment owner of
French Football Club Paris sgain Daily
Mail publisher DMG Ventures and the
parent company of the New York Yankees
baseball team big names from the World
of Sport are also throwing their weight
behind paddle so when you think about
institutional investment that is looking
for those Returns on a sport like paddle
Returns on their investment this is a
high growth opportunity for them but
there's also the other aspect of it of
individuals that play tennis potentially
or other celebrities athletes that just
want to be involved in a growing game
that are looking at paddle as another
growth opportunity for them for their
brand and also to inspire the Next
[Music]
Generation in London's Canary wolf a
major international finance Center a
project backed by Spotify co-founder
Martin lorensen is hoping to tap been a
growing demand to play paddle among
white color
workers so we're actually standing on
top of 15 me of scaffold the place we're
on was supposed to become a skyscraper
but in a post-pandemic world where
there's not as much as a need of offices
we had the opportunity to reuse the land
to build a paddle Club me I'm originally
from uh Sweden I grew up there and I uh
discovered the game four or five years
ago uh I played it and during one of my
trips back back to back home and I
really in love with the game but then I
had to try to play the game continue
picking it up here in London but there
were very few courts and booking them
was closely impossible so that's what
the idea came to to mind of maybe I
should get involved in this uh business
the reaction since we launched has been
really really good I was expecting us to
get busy but maybe not this quickly
onwards our Prime times after 400 p.m.
is pretty much booked out every single
day our weekends are pretty much booked
out as well but the mornings and
afternoons requires a bit more of a
community to to fill those hours but the
uptick has been
amazing so I think it's one of our
responsibilities as as a club in the
location where we are to educate people
about paddle the UK is still a very
early emerging marketing paddle and a
lot of people don't know what it is
they've never played it so what we do is
we we we do a run of lots of
introduction to paddle uh sessions where
people can come and try it out for for
one session and learn the basic rules
and then from there be ready to play a
game soon we will also be running Junior
to even get the kids involved and build
a bit of a grassroot sport investors
looking to ride the paddle wave face a
number of challenges space is hard to
come by planning restrictions can be
tough to navigate and the pool of
existing players in New Markets like the
US and the UK is still relatively small
but with the number of Courts globally
expected to almost double by the end of
20126 many more people should soon get
the chance to pick up a bat and try
their hand at one of the world world's
fastest growing
Sports